once you start thinking from an
evolutionary perspective if there's some
feature of the organism that is species
typical if humans across the world have
tendencies toward anxiety especially
under the same kinds of conditions then
instead of saying oh anxiety feels bad
let's get rid of it well why don't we
step back and say what is this what's
the function of it what is the
evolutionary function why is this part
of our evolve psychology and then in
treating it you have a different
perspective
glengare welcome to the show hey thanks
so much for having me chris
something that i think is really
interesting is that there's been a paleo
movement around food and training but
there hasn't really seemed to be an
equivalent around psychology there's no
sort of paleo psychologists or at least
people that have taken that and tried to
apply it to their own lives i haven't
seen many people walking around doing
paleo psychology yet
paleo psychology that's a great phrase i
wish i would have come up with that
myself
it's a really good question so
when we talk about the paleo lifestyle
or the paleo movement
um most people are familiar with the the
dietary component of it and honestly as
someone who teaches about evolution and
the human experience that is the most
vivid and easiest example to get across
to people um it makes sense
it matches data people can sort of see
their own behavior and and think about
it and just the idea of eating too much
processed food leading to health
problems is you know kind of something
that we all know and then this really
puts sort of a
scientific framework around it so the
the paleo
the paleo diet and the paleo solution
related to exercise and nutrition tons
of sense and and it's definitely a
reasonably well established movement at
this point um
but as as you're talking about um
this broader concept of paleopsychology
which really is i think
an interesting way of framing what i'm
calling positive evolutionary psychology
um using evolutionary psychology to help
us lead
better lives to understand ourselves
better to lead better
community lives and to help advance the
goals of our communities and so forth
and positive kinds of ways it turns out
that the same reasoning that you can
apply to the paleo diet movement really
can be applied to many issues regarding
our emotional
social functioning as well and i think
that
that's really very much untapped at this
point and i'm i'm hoping to be part of
you know maybe even just a small part
but part of the solution to sort of get
get people in a broader sense to think
about um how broadly applicable this
evolutionary perspective is with all
aspects of our lives
is there something that's missing from
positive psychology which evolutionary
psychology adds in i know that for a
long time psychology was focused on all
of the malignant parts and biases and
how we mess up and then positive
psychology came along and said well we
should probably try and actually improve
people's lives as well that would be a
useful thing but then
i'm trying to work out what it is that's
missing from positive psych that is
added into by evolutionary psychology
sure it's a really good question um and
if you go back to the history
of the two fields evolutionary
psychology and positive and positive
psychology
it's super interesting that they have
there's a lot of parallels
so
they're both considered relatively new
fields within psychology they both
started arguably in the 90s
in a lot of ways
positive psychology emerged when martin
seligman became president of the
american psychological association and
really made a a big
call to behavioral scientists
and practitioners
saying you know exactly what you're
talking about what why can't you know
why can't we study the positive features
of the human experience scientifically
so that we can amplify
the good and the positive which i think
is you know i'm totally on board with
that message and with a lot of the work
that's been done
evolutionary psychology really started i
mean it started and stopped over the
years ever since darwin in a lot of ways
but the current movement
started very much in the 90s with people
like david bus stephen pinker
lita cosmis and john tubey
and
um
really said you know we need to
think about everything in in when it
comes to human behavior
relative to
our evolutionary history so
um i think that field has been very
powerful and successful at helping shed
light on things like human emotions
human relationships
um human sexuality human aggression
social interactions like tons and tons
of fields and when
my co-author nicole wedberg and i were
thinking about this
idea of positive evolutionary psychology
the the big insight that we had was you
know positive psychology is great but if
you look at
the literature
in the journals the academic journals of
positive psychology such as the journal
of happiness studies and so forth and
the main textbooks in the field
it's it's
very devoid of evolutionary thinking um
and it doesn't seem intentionally so you
know i think generally speaking
behavioral and social scientists
have not been trained in evolutionary
thinking
across the years i you know that's a
whole separate um thread that i could go
down
but
you know positive psychologists that
don't have that training and so when you
read their their articles their
scientific work the general theme
tends to be how can we make people
happier and
chris i'm not going to say that's a bad
goal at all i'm not going to argue
against that as a goal
but when you start thinking about things
from an evolutionary perspective
that starts to look like a very limited
um
very limited approach to sort of what we
should be doing in terms of trying to
advance humans advance our society
advance our scholarly work so the idea
that we came up with well why don't we
do what we can to evolutionize
positive psychology see if we can
integrate
these two these two fields
and i will tell you um quickly that my
my co-author nicole and i went to a
symposium one time it was all positive
psychology research presentations was
held on our campus it was really as you
can imagine it was a positive experience
mostly given by students they
had really great projects
they had done some great reading
proposed and implemented a bunch of
great research
and the insight that nicole and i had
after talking to every presenter and
looking at every
presentation was that
not a single one of them mentioned or
even came close to thinking about things
from an evolutionary perspective and i'm
going to say that without exception
make what can we do to make people
happier seem to be
the singular goal of each and every
project and that's when we were like you
know what we gotta we gotta do our part
to shed some light
on on this situation which is um you
know how can we look at the goals of
positive psychology but within an
evolutionary framework and maybe that'll
be a more powerful way to actually try
to implement some of these values and
ideas well we derive satisfaction from
life on a lot of other pathways than
simply happiness right there's a lot of
other things that contribute to living a
good life than being happy all of the
time and i suppose thinking at it from
the reverse thinking about what the
potential holes in evolutionary
psychology that are filled by positive
psychology are a lot of
eve psych consists of
harsh truths and uncomfortable realities
about our genuine uh less than admirable
motivations for the things that we do
absolutely absolutely um
evolutionary psychology is pretty famous
for studying the dark side of the human
experience
um and you know there's a general
negativity bias that people have so you
know even if
even if a good percentage of
evolutionary psychological research has
not been on the dark side you know
negative dark things tend to stand out
in our minds just as an example
we had a great speaker on campus the
other day virtually
um presenting and it was todd
shackleford who's um
really renowned uh alum of david buss
and now he oversees the psychology
department at oakland university
in michigan and he's published a ton
largely on facets of sperm competition
and how that relates to behavior and
infidelity no way
oh oh yeah yeah great great research and
he gave a talk
that's the specific
concept then he had multiple studies on
this was the phrase he used was forced
in pair copulation
um which is essentially
um i almost feel like after like trigger
warning with something like this is
essentially like rape within uh within a
pairing with a monogamous pairing
and
he presented data this is not an
altogether uncommon experience um
you know and he gave
fantastic and well thought out
evolution-based reasoning for the
conditions under which this happens and
how it connects with
infidelity and how it connects with
paternal uncertainty and a lot of these
things that you know are bread and
butter and evolutionary psychology
and i'll tell you i thought it was i
thought it was terrific um there were a
few students who who heard it that i
think were were kind of upset about the
nature of the content
and you know i got thinking this it was
such such a great presentation but it's
almost and this is without any offense
at all to todd or people who are doing
similar kind of research i think it's
important research i think that we need
to embrace and be open-minded about
studying any and all topics within the
academy but you can see the pr issue you
know
right
like you can see like well there's a pr
issue in everything to do with
evolutionary psychology as far as i can
see like look at david buss's most
recent one men behaving badly or bad men
i think it was in america or in the uk
in the uk right
dude that was it's an entire book
telling you that all of the things that
you think that you value in your partner
adaptations to try and get around your
own sexual defenses that you're
basically in a predator prey
um
it's analogous to predators and play
that pray that we have one party that
gets a new type of trick and then the
other one has to learn about how the
trick works to then dampen that down
our motivations for most of the things
that we do they're not it's not that
they're not virtuous but they're not as
pure
as we think that they are they often
come from a place which is significantly
more zero-sum it's significantly more
competitive it's significantly less
altruistic sure
absolutely absolutely um and it's funny
because i know david reasonably well and
i think the world of him and his
research
um
i but i do think
that he's almost been too successful and
what i mean by that is his research on
sex differences and human mating and our
evolved psychology surrounding mating
has been so
um so prolific
and that's
one of the things and there's like
you're saying there's multiple things in
evolutionary psych but that's one of the
things an evolutionary psych that makes
a lot of people in the modern landscape
feel uncomfortable about
you know ideas
that makes a lot of sense it would be
nice if if david busses is looking at
some of the darker aspects of human
nature through an evolutionary lens it
would be nice to have somebody who is
equally well known uh but looking at
some of the lighter sides but i suppose
you're right it's just less
it's less attention-grabbing
yeah who wants to know that you're nicer
than you actually thought you were right
you know it's just not going to grab
headlines so do you think
is that one of the big hurdles because
i'm
fascinated by evolutionary psychology
and constantly surprised i'm also
fascinated by the fact that it hasn't
been integrated into modern society
tremendously well right right
yeah it's i think that's it's it's quite
fascinating that way um
i think that you know someone like like
david has been you know he's been so
prolific
um there have been
if you step back there have been efforts
and attempts to to study the bright side
of
our experience from an evolutionary
perspective a good example is david
sloane wilson
of binghamton who studies and has
studied altruism very extensively and he
studies religion but from like a very
evolution based scientific perspective
and and he's for you know for a secular
scientist david i think is very um
very
kind to to religious ideology kind of
talking about how it's steeped in our
evolutionary history and what are the
benefits and what are the communal
benefits and you know why did why was
this such a successful
approach to to organizing human social
interaction so
um
so i think that there actually is quite
a bit of stuff on on all
sorts of things about human behavior and
and community and interactions but you
know i will tell you when you ask people
what do you think about evolutionary
styke a very high proportion of people
say oh that's the stuff that says that
men and women are different and that you
know it justifies males bad behavior and
this kind of thing and it's like
you hear this from person after person
i'm like no that's you know this is like
it's like there's a pie and this is like
maybe a small slice of it that's kind of
related to what people are talking about
but man they hear that and they latch on
to it so
that's something quite interesting
because a lot of the time when you bring
up the fact that people who are perhaps
on the left
might have an issue with some of the
conclusions that are drawn from
evolutionary psychology um and most of
the responses to that are these people
on the left are idiots they're denying
the way that we work blah blah blah but
another interesting way to look at this
is you could you also are not only
getting a perhaps overzealous response
from the people but you're also not
showing everything from the subject area
as well there's another big bit of this
which is being missed off that's a
an interesting way to look at it
yeah yeah
some of the stats that you mentioned you
have in the introduction you have a
couple of a couple of interesting
insights here men are more than twice as
likely to experience early mortality
death during young adulthood compared
with women is that risk-taking
it's related to risk taking yeah this is
the work of um dan kruger and randy
nessie
um really super interesting and i i like
to present this um
to give people a sense of how
relevant and important evolutionary
psychology is because some sometimes
people say well that stuff doesn't
really matter it doesn't pertain to the
modern world it's not it doesn't address
important social issues and uh the stuff
on male to female mortality ratio is is
huge it's a very reliable set of
findings so dan kruger who's an
evolutionary psychologist who works in a
school of public health at university of
michigan he has access to all kinds of
health related data
and started with his then mentor randy
nessie um who you know coined the term
darwinian medicine huge huge scholar in
the field
he said well mortality is a pretty big
health health related issue and i have a
whole bunch of evolution-based
predictions surrounding mortality and so
so dan was essentially empowered to
start looking at this and what he found
was you know it's been known for quite a
while
that
males
terms of
in terms of simply survival and
mortality don't do as well as women men
live shorter lives they're more likely
to die at different life stages than our
our women for various kinds of reasons
and that had been known but what dan
added to in his research was he said
based on
evolutionary reasoning since mating is
so
intensive and competitive
and mating
mate selection in particular sort of
starts in the late teens and and you
know peaks and maybe the early to mid
20s
we would expect that to be a
part of life where men are particularly
more likely to out-die
women
you know i can't really that's the best
i can in terms of how i can word it and
and what he found was exactly that that
that men always males always um are more
likely to die than women at every
population that's been studied at every
age but
when you get to the teenage about 15 to
25 you see a big peak um huge like
there's a huge spike in the data and
then it kind of smooths smooths out a
little bit and i'm like
that's relevant you know if you think
that's not if you think that's
irrelevant to societal functioning you
know i got news for you if
if it under if it helps us understand
life and death for you know
you know millions of people at any given
time
i'd say that's highly relevant and
something that we would do better just
understanding so but that's when men are
getting into gangs that's when men are
doing antisocial behavior it's when
their testosterone levels are highest
and then it starts to taper off toward
the end of their 20s so when they're
getting into prison it's when they're
causing the most violent crimes it's
when they're most likely i'm going to
guess probably to be killed or to kill
someone both both and physical causes um
so so dan divided things into what he
calls internal versus external causes of
death and these effects were were big
for both kind but they were particularly
exacerbated for what he called external
causes so that is
fights and and murder and homicide um
and things that he calls like like
um risky kinds of things car crashes
yeah exactly the reason that that men
are paying higher you know young men are
paying higher insurance rates than
than young women is employee races yeah
it's all tied into the same exact thing
there's a phrase um
to capture this put forward by
uh dalian wilson other some other folks
who sort of
carved out the field and the phrase is
young male syndrome
um and the idea is that you know young
men who engage in risky behavior to the
point that it can be dangerous and lead
to all kinds of
adverse outcomes including
premature death um that's that's a
natural feature of the male experience
um you know in other words when we see
this kind of stuff it's not like oh that
guy's an idiot you know it's it's what
it is is that that's part of the male
developmental experience and it's so
common um those kinds of things are so
common and then if you think about like
shows like i remember i used to watch
the show jackass which i remember like
that's it's just guys you know it's guys
being stupid it's young men being stupid
um and
and risky and all those young men being
stupid but johnny knoxville's in his
late 40s or 50s now and they've come
back and done jackass three and stevo's
back in it and everyone else's
and that's just come out so uh i think
they might be outliers that just haven't
learned their lesson but
you're totally correct
what what's adaptive about that
risk-taking behavior for you and what
would have been adaptive about that
super high risk-taking behavior for
young men sure well
you know as is true in in most sexually
reproducing species um not everyone gets
to reproduce you know and from an
evolutionary perspective
reproduction is what i like to call
darwin's bottom line um
and
being shut out of reproduction from an
evolutionary perspective is something
that
you would totally expect any and all
kinds of adaptations to emerge to
prevent being shut out of reproduction
because any of our ancestors that didn't
reproduce didn't become ancestors so the
ones who did reproduce had whatever
behavioral and physical
adaptations that
ultimately cultivated reproduction
so
i think
you know then you step back and be like
well why are men like young men like
this and and mathematically the answer
essentially is
that
it's a risky strategy
under some conditions it's going to lead
to early death or adverse outcomes but
it's also
likely that the benefits the
reproductive benefits on average over
large periods of time
likely outweighed
the
survival related costs you know the same
same reason that the peacock's tail
emerged you know a lot of peacocks died
at the at the teeth of tigers you know
but
the ones who reproduced on average you
know they had the they had the house
edge
yeah dude it's so i mean that's a really
good way to look at it and i suppose
this sort of summarizes one of the key
issues that you find
with the modern era which is this
mismatch right which is that we are
designed for one particular type of
environment and now we're living in
another and this mismatch causes us
unhappiness or trauma or
just as a sub-optimal um approach to the
way that we live
yeah definitely um i feel like the idea
of mismatch is so powerful and
it's
it is something that we've only
scratched the surface i feel like it is
so relevant it's so powerful
um
and what i like about it from a from a
pr perspective is it's very different
like once
when you start talking to students or
other academics about a lot of the stuff
um like the male female differences that
kind of stuff people start getting they
politicize it and start going down all
kinds of rabbit holes but when you start
talking to people about you know
generally speaking if you look at the
human mind and our experience
and the conditions under which our
ancestors evolved
it's night and day there are so many
obvious and important mismatches between
the modern world and the world that we
evolve to live in and and i feel like
people people across you know all kinds
of ideologies and backgrounds can really
connect
with this particular message
i like to
to think about it as a very simple way
to think about is the fishing of a fish
that gets out of the fishbowl
i was teaching for a few years it was
great experience i was teaching
evolution-based classes in china and
they were all second english as a second
language learners
and i remember i gave a whole what i
thought was a really great lecture on
mismatch and a very bright student came
up to me
her name was vicky and she said
professor we don't understand what you
just said and it was like after an hour
and a half of lecturing i was like oh
man
so i went back to my hotel room i
thought about it i came back the next
day and i'm like raise your hand if you
ever had a pet fish you know half the
kids raised their hand i'm like you ever
see the fish you ever have that
experience where you go in your room and
it's on the carpet dead and i'm like the
students made a face like a bunch of
them you know going to raise their hand
at that i'm like well that's because the
ancestors of the fish
were completely aquatic and all the
adaptations of the fish are completely
designed for a fully aquatic
experience kind of thing and you know so
i use that as an example of
now think about um then i think i i talk
about
the monkey in the the cage and
and
um all the work by henry harry harlow
what's the story there well so he you
know he's he's famous for showing how um
infant monkeys he's kind of famous for
traumatizing young monkeys so he did
research in in labs at i think it was
one of the uc schools years ago
and if you take a monkey away from a
little baby monkey away from its mom
these were rhesus monkeys and macaques
he was using um and you give it a choice
of a mother a fake mother that's either
like a stuffed animal kind of like a
fluffy monkey like um stuffed animal
versus
a fake mother that's wire like made out
of metal and but has milk
on it
um like
the the monkeys are torn because they
they feel the comfort of the one
and but they need the milk from the
other
but a secondary
you know so that's a lesson on like on
on natural impulses regarding need for
for maternal care kind of thing but a
secondary thing is all the monkeys that
were in his research
um who were taken away from their
mothers for experimental purposes when
they were released with the rest of the
colony that he had
they were messed up and
they weren't able to um engage in
regular appropriate mating behavior or
friendship behavior or coalitional
behavior they really showed just a deep
set of problems and
you could think about it as well their
experiences were completely mismatched
under ancestral conditions little baby
monkeys weren't taken out of their
natural environment for several years
and then sorry my light goes off
automatically
modern technology right
um
you know
and so and this is the reason
um
in new york the uh the bronx zoo when i
was a kid i would go to the bronx zoo
all the time and they had this great
place called the monkey house and the
monkey house was like this big old
building
and had maybe
50 um cages and the cages just had
random monkeys sometimes they were with
the same species sometimes not sometimes
there was like a log in there kind of
thing to try to make it seem a little
bit natural-ish and in 2012 the bronx
zoo closed the monkey house and
worse they turned it into administrative
offices
um but you know from a mismatch
perspective you can totally see it you
know at some point zoologists figured
out
wait a minute this is
we're we're torturing these animals
they're we're putting them in mismatched
conditions they're showing stress
responses they're showing anxiety
responses and so forth and
it only makes sense when once you start
to think about things from the
evolutionary perspective and from the
mismatch perspective in particular so
the next step is well let's take a look
at
at the modern human experience and look
at us you know engaging in like a skype
conversation
look at us you know sitting in our our
chairs you know artificial light on an
artificial light sure um and engaging in
interactions a lot of times with
strangers so you were just saying before
you're in new york city i mean the
number of strangers that you see if you
walk
down a block in new york city on a busy
day
hundreds or even thousands and
you don't think anything of it but under
ancestral conditions we didn't
experience strangers regularly and when
we did it usually meant that there was
some danger or some kind of
problem so
you know modern evolutionary
psychologists have really started
thinking about
how many in how many ways
are our modern conditions mismatched
from the environments that we evolved to
be in
and maybe we're kind of
like like the fish in the fishbowl maybe
it's like we're so surrounded by these
conditions and have been our whole lives
at that it's hard to question it you
know so i feel like the evolutionary
perspective gives us like the tools the
infrastructure to actually question some
of these things and i think that's
that's really very very powerful and can
lead to a lot of positive changes but
the question here is
which of the new
adaptations which of the mismatches are
actually beneficial the fact that i
don't need to go and go to a stream to
get water i just had it in a bottle here
or the fact that i can be
cooler when it's warm or warmer when
it's cool you know those those are good
things what are the things that we have
as a part of society and specifically
for you that are making us
psychologically unhealthy so what would
be
some of the big the big problems that
you've got or what would be the main the
main enemies in terms of mismatch it's a
that's such a great question um and as
you know i've thought about this quite
quite a bit
over the past several years a lot of the
research in my lab has been on this
question we've demonstrated that modern
public education is mismatched in a
whole bunch of ways that can have
adverse effects modern politics
is mismatched we've done research
showing that humans are not really good
at processing large-scale politics you
know so if you see like why is the
political world
such a mess these days um you know part
of the reason is because our minds
evolve for small-scale politics and not
large-scale politics and and the one
that i've focused on quite a bit of late
that i'm really interested in
is
um i guess what we'd have to call like
social media or like modern
communication systems
under ancestral conditions if you were
going to communicate with someone it was
going to be face to face and that was it
you know that was the only choice for
lion's share of human evolutionary
history and if you're face to face
with with someone that you know
your interactions are going to be very
different than if you're anonymous and
you're dealing with a stranger
and if you're anonymous in dealing with
a stranger and you're communicating
through a screen
you know suddenly like the number of
mismatches that creep into it are
enormous so when i teach about this i'll
ask my students they'll say what
percentage of your just write down what
percentage of your communications with
other people in the last week
has been of the non-face-to-face variety
and on average we usually see about set
they'll say 70 80 percent
you know and i've i've got to tell you
you know that's
it's for for my generation that's that's
starting to to be true as well you know
we used to sort of laugh at the young
kids in their cell phones and now
everyone you know grandmas grandpas
everyone's addicted to their cell phones
and and it's such a problem because you
know like you're saying chris there's
the number of benefits that come from
this are obvious you know the way
the simple way to think about it is you
know with this with this simple thing
right here i can
ask and answer any question in the
entire history of the world within one
second yeah you know like every
at any moment at any time it's it's
crazy um
the the power that that has i can
communicate with people immediately if i
have a family member that that is in
trouble i can immediately
provide kind of financial or some other
kind of help so the benefits are all i
think very obvious and we think quite a
bit about those benefits
what we don't see
because again because we're the fish in
the fishbowl what we don't see is the
problems associated with it and when you
start thinking about it from a mismatch
perspective man there are problems so
i'll give one example anonymous
communication
under ancestral conditions there wasn't
anonymous communication and in fact we
kind of evolved to be a little a little
skittish about anonymous communication
so
you know when you go to the grocery
store someone has their their name badge
on
when a student comes into my class i say
hi i'm glenn you know what's your name
your your name's on the roster
doctors introduce themselves by name
if you think about the professions where
anonymity
um is part of what they're doing it's
really rare um i'd like to give the
example of clowns you know i wrote a
whole piece about why why clown phobia
is pretty common like well clowns are
like that's like the only job where
you're you're hiding your identity you
know they have a made up name they got
this they're they're in a mask they're
in a costume they don't break character
like that's creepy you know but it's
partly creepy because under ancestral
conditions
we were only dealing with people in a
face-to-face variety
on top of that when you look at research
on anti-social behavior the best way to
get people to do bad things is hide
their identity um
so you did a halloween there was a
halloween experiment about this yeah
yeah exactly what was that exactly so
this is a study done by deaner in the
1970s where they brought kids um
kids were trick-or-treating and so the
kids were going to this one particular
house where they were videotaping the
kids and they
measured whether the kids were wearing
um a mask or not you know some some
halloween uh costumes have masks and
some don't of course and they looked at
whether kids were in a group or not
because when you're in a group your own
identity kind of gets diffused and then
they did the classic where they put out
the bucket on the front porch
and that bucket almost without fail will
have the freeze you know on a yellow
posted saying take one like you know
everyone knows the rule
and so of course kids are kids and
they're not going to always take one and
what they found was that both of those
variables if they were in a group kids
each individual kid was more likely to
take a whole handful and if their
identity was hidden if if they're if
they were wearing a mask people couldn't
tell who they were if they were darth
vader or this kind of thing under that
condition they were also more likely to
engage in anti-social behavior and just
like snag
snag a whole bunch what do you think the
effect on the group says is that just
diffusion of responsibility
yeah yeah so diffusion of responsibility
is a phrase that a lot of behavioral
scientists will will use for that where
um
you know it's it's an ironic finding and
the finding essentially is that when
there's more
people and there's a bigger group of
people
um
people each individual has less feels
and experiences less responsibility for
whatever's going on so people are more
likely to do the wrong thing especially
if other people are doing it they're
less likely to help someone in need and
this kind of thing
one ironic thing on that is that if you
need help you want fewer people around
rather than more people around there's
those stories about um blocks of flats
and somebody
being attacked downstairs and nobody
calling the police because everybody
presumes that somebody else is going to
call the police yeah absolutely what do
you think's happening
ancestrally
with that effect there is it the fact
that reciprocal altruism and sympathy
and empathy and kindness and giving and
stuff like that are less necessary if
you're in a group because you already
have support of other people therefore
giving away something when you already
have that support
to an extra person doesn't make as much
sense
that's that's super interesting i had
never thought about it quite that way
but i think that certainly might
contribute partly to this
so this idea of reciprocal altruism um
came from trivers is a huge huge
renowned
figure in the field
and essentially said that we evolved a
lot of adaptations around the fact that
humans engage in reciprocal altruism and
that's a very basic feature of who we
are and what we do so i help you you
help me
and and our species fits a lot of the
criteria of that which is we generally
live in stable groups so we see the same
individuals over and over we have good
memory for individual faces and voices
and that kind of thing
um
and we live relatively long lives so
there's like a long you know arc of time
to sort of
pay people back but but that gets
screwed up when we're dealing with
strangers right because reciprocal
altruism evolved under conditions where
we were surrounded by members of our
clan you know small clans where you knew
every individual
game yeah yeah exactly exactly so once
once we're dealing with strangers
everything gets
a lot of our evolved psychology wasn't
it wasn't designed for that so things
like reciprocal altruism like if i'm in
a group and we're all part of a team and
we know each other and we're going to
see each other tomorrow and then there's
someone who needs help who's outside the
group i'm like well that's a stranger
who's never going to help me and might
even be dangerous for me so so many of
these these things that that we might
get like outraged about and i can't
believe people did this or that or
didn't help a lot of it can really be
understood by this idea that so many of
the modern situations we might run into
are outside the bounds of what our minds
would have evolved to experience
that's just in-group out-group mentality
but i suppose if you're part of a group
it's easier to find an out-group as
opposed to if you are on your own if
there is just two of you then you might
behave in more of that sort of
reciprocally altruistic way what did you
learn about
education
yeah so that that was a really
fascinating area to get into um
so you know we have public um obligatory
public education and that's true in so
much of the modern world these days
and
i had a student named katie gruskin who
was um she was in my evolutionary
studies seminar and became super
interested in she just started thinking
about education she was an ed major and
she was thinking about education from an
evolutionary perspective so i pointed
her toward the literature of peter gray
who's at boston college he's written
extensively about education from an
evolutionary perspective
the skinny of what he finds is that
modern
public school systems have very
mismatched and unnatural ways of
educating young kids this idea of
sitting you know having um kids in the
same age so like age stratification is
one problem everyone here is 10 and
there's 30 of you and there's one 30
year old woman over there and you're
gonna sit there for eight hours every
single day and listen to what that
person says and the knowledge that
you're gonna get is what we might call
secondary instead of primary knowledge
so instead of like learning how to do
something which is under ancestral
conditions what education would have
looked like we're like writing about it
and instead of like you know throwing a
ball and seeing what happens we're like
writing about the physics of it and arcs
and the math of it that stuff's you know
it's important but we have such a such a
focus on that kind of
secondary knowledge um
there's less time for play there's
there's less time for natural
interactions there's less time for mixed
age kinds of groups
and you know one of the outcomes
associated with that is you tend to see
tons of kids and it seems to increase
every year
are diagnosed with attentional kinds of
problems and are given prescriptions for
for pharmaceuticals
and you know maybe the problem is not
the kid maybe the problems the situation
so my student katie did a whole study
that really took this approach
of thinking of schools
as a as derivative of factory mindsets
and so when you look at when public
schools were started largely in the uk
actually is um where her research took
her um
it was you know the bell rings at the
factory and everyone's gonna start
working and the bell rings again and
it's it's lunch time and this kind of
thing used the same bells
in schools as they did in factories
that's what katie had said yeah yeah the
same bells i mean if that's not showing
the hand of the ruthless capitalists
that are trying to compromise the
proletariats labor i don't know what is
exactly exactly um
and you know there's so so many
mismatches so that's like the entire
idea and now we don't even question it
you know it's like i was saying that i
think that whole thing about like we're
so much of of what we have is just
you don't question it you know most of
us don't like public schools public
school you got to go to school you got
to do this you got to learn that because
that's because that's what we do but if
you step back and be like wait a minute
where did this come from
you know why is it like this and what
peter gray did and katie leaned a lot on
his research for her work
what he did was he looked extensively at
what does learning and education look
like
in pre-westernized societies or nomadic
societies of which there's you know
lots of examples of nomadic societies
in africa and in the pacific islands in
south america you know lots of places
and the common theme he found was
there's not a single thing that looks at
all
like public
like public education
that kids that the word learning and
playing and education
none of those concepts are teased apart
in in these uh pre-westernized groups
and
regularly kids are learning from other
kids that the main teachers in
pre-westernized nomadic societies
aren't adults but they're kids that are
usually slightly older so an
eight-year-old might learn from a
twelve-year-old and a sixteen-year-old
might might be teaching something to a
fifteen-year-old or a fourteen-year-old
and
they're they're learning while they're
playing them all they're just kind of
out for the day and interacting wow that
is wildly different than sit down and
take this standardized test and use
number two pencil and if you can't do it
take this pill
you know and we're gonna have to talk to
your mom and dad because there's
something to matter with you and
you know it's it i feel like this
mismatch perspective really forces us to
step back and just look at the problems
we have and just step back and think
about them from this this deeper level
and i feel like
it's powerful
and what katie found the short version
of her work and she published it in
evolutionary
behavioral science
sciences
was
that
she asked people she gave a whole list
of things that that are typical of
nomadic education nomadic learning
context
um learning in groups learning in mixed
age groups um
less more project-based kinds of kinds
of experiences and what she found was
people who reported a higher proportion
of those experiences in their own
elementary school experiences
like school better later and did better
school at all levels later than that so
to the extent that we can like step back
and and this kind of goes to your
original question about like
paleopsychology like how can we use this
perspective not just for what we eat and
nutrition
and that kind of thing but for sort of
our broader paleo education paleo
education exactly exactly and there's
you know there's something to it
going on to the emotions that you looked
at what did you learn about kindness i
find this quite an interesting
um
an interesting thing to think about
evolutionarily because
kindness is one of those
it's quite bizarre why you would decide
to give away some of your time or feel a
compulsion to help another person we're
told you know survival of the fittest
that evolution is this sort of ruthless
tool kindness appears to be a little bit
of a
an interesting dynamic in that
absolutely absolutely so
i kindness from an evolutionary
perspective is super interesting for all
the reasons that you just pointed out
and
you know one of the things
about kindness is we like it in mates
you know let me just kind of start there
i'll sort of unpack things a bit more
from there but when david buss you know
probably the the best known
figure in the field or certainly one of
them and it's a great guy and a great
researcher you know when he did his
famous research in the late 80s early
90s about what the people want in mates
what got famously amplified from that
was how men and women want different
things across lots of cultures and
that's true
but the
the headline the um that really got sort
of dismissed
is that kindness and mutual love were
for both men and women
across pretty much all these cultures
number one that was ubiquitous yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly and and you know
there's something very
um
it's not as sexy you know it's it's it's
you know people are like well that's
that's fine but wow men like this and
women don't and women like it's easier
to say oh men are after youth and
fertility and women are after resources
and status then both of them are after
kindness and i saw a recent study on
this uh that just came out
last month and um humor
is up there for both both men and women
absolutely for for lots yeah for lots of
good reasons so you know one of the
reasons that kindness exists is
you know if it's effective in securing a
mate and if it's effective in
maintaining an effective mate ship then
it's going to be selected you know
that's kind of evolution 101 um in a in
a sexually reproducing species so even
though that didn't get a lot of air time
with with the the findings from what
boss and his colleagues
found you know it's really really
critical and it makes it makes a lot of
sense you know if you have a kind mate
then that means that that's someone that
you can trust your feelings with you can
be vulnerable with you can expect that
person to help you and to provide you
benefits and then it becomes a
reciprocal altruism kind of thing where
you know you're providing benefits
back and forth and that kind of thing so
and again kindness doesn't exist in
every species but we're species where we
evolve to be surrounded by the same
individuals over long periods of time
and that
social
ecosystem
has to be considered strongly when we
think about our evolved psychology so
under that kind of condition it makes
sense that kindness would evolve because
individuals need to get along with one
another and
if someone gets a reputation as
exploitative
or you know
stealing from others and not putting in
their fair share they're going to be
outed by others you know and they might
end up being ostracized or punished in
various kinds of ways
so i think that the importance of
kindness as essentially an adaptation
um that helps make people attracted as
attractive as mates as friends we're
doing a study right now about leadership
and
there's multiple paths toward toward
leadership
some leaders become leaders because
they're they're ruthless and
intimidating and selfish and scary um
and some people become leaders because
they're so kind and genuine and other
oriented that people trust them and like
yes this person has my interest in mind
um so i i think that that kindness
certainly has a place in the in the
human evolutionary
story for for lots of different reasons
i suppose that you can see quite easily
here how the evolutionary mismatch is is
at play because
in the modern world we can live
on our own in an airbnb getting food
delivered to us and we're safe because
the police have the streets and we're
warm because there's electricity and
heating and we don't need other people
you know if you have sufficient
resources you can go through your entire
life basically not interacting with
other people and apart from maybe over
the internet at your remote work job um
but the difference is we would have
never been able to survive
on our own
previously and that kindness would have
engendered other people to want to help
us it would have meant that we would
have been less likely speaking of that
actually
what i know this isn't
specifically what you looked at but i'm
fascinated by the evolutionary um
explanation for depression and anxiety
have you ever looked at that
yeah yeah absolutely um and that's
something else that we we cover a bit in
the book um
it's really interesting because from a
positive psychology perspective
generally speaking
um eradicating negative affect negative
emotional states seems to be a paramount
goal you know and trust me i don't like
anxiety or depression as much as as the
next guy
but you know there's a great anecdote
that i include
i included in part of the book by randy
nessie so
randy
coined the term darwinian medicine has
published extensively including several
books on darwinian psychiatry
and how all the mental and physical
health fields will benefit from being
darwinized and evolutionized and his
backgrounds as a psychiatrist and he had
this great anecdote that led him to
thinking this way
which was um he was working at the
university of michigan and one of his he
was doing therapy in addition to his his
faculty position
and he had a
a client who was also a professor in a
different department
and the client said he was pretty
anxious and so
randy talked to him and then prescribed
him some anti-anxiety pills
you know the equivalent of xanax at the
time and said
come back in a month and talk to me and
the guy came back
and i said all right well how are you
doing he said well i feel i feel good
i'm not anxious anymore and so randy's
like all right and he said but there's
still a problem he's like well what is
it
and he's like well i got a pile of
papers this big on my desk and i don't
care to grade them whatsoever and the
students are knocking on my door and how
come you're not doing your work and
what's up with you
and apparently that motivation to sort
of get that stuff done
went away with the anxiety which gave
nessie the insight of wait a minute
maybe the negative affective states such
as anxiety
as unpleasant as they may be
have a very important evolutionary
function and
you know once you start thinking from an
evolutionary perspective if there's some
feature of the organism
that is species typical if humans
across the world have tendencies toward
anxiety especially under certain kinds
of
the same kinds of conditions then
instead of saying oh anxiety feels bad
let's get rid of it
you know well why don't we step back and
say you know what is this
why what's the function of it what is
the evolutionary function why is this
part of our evolve psychology and then
in treating it
you have a different perspective
you know you can step back and say we
don't want to just get rid of anxiety we
want to keep it controlled so it's not
like running someone's life
but
this idea of making everyone just as
happy and free of anxiety and so forth
as possible that doesn't make any
evolutionary sense what about depression
depressions uh i'd say very similar um
very similar there's a guy matt keller
who i think i know he was at the
university of colorado i think he may
still be there very bright scholar
[Music]
published
research a while back
really extensively looking at depression
from an evolutionary lens and it was he
was asking the same questions he was
like well instead of just getting rid of
depression which obviously you know
depression
can be can be debilitating and have all
kinds of adverse outcomes it's like but
what what might be the evolutionary
function of depression it's essentially
the the question and what he found
was even though the dsm which is the
main book that's used for diagnosing
mental psychopathologies and mental
health issues
on a large global scale
the dsm at that time when it talked
about depression it it did not take and
it still doesn't it didn't take an
evolutionary approach so it just had all
these symptoms and if you've had these
symptoms over this amount of time then
you know we're going to call you
depressed and what what matt keller
found
was that depression can actually come
about by multiple pathways and
probably the best way to address
depression is to think about the pathway
that led to it the two specific
contrasting examples he gave one was the
loss of a loved one so loss of a loved
one is a classic catalyst for depression
people might become depressed depending
on the the closeness of the
of the relationship and so forth for
extensive periods of time
and when people lose a loved one they
tend to reach out to others and try to
form
social connections so a common thing
that's found in people who have
depression caused by loss
is a reaching out to others whereas
another catalyst for
depression is
an error a major error you messed
something up there was something that
was your fault you failed at something
cheat on your partner
yes yeah messed up you can't take it
back it becomes public this kind of
thing and with this kind of thing the
depression that follows from that
people don't reach out to others people
withdraw people stay stay in bed late
people stop eating people like i don't
want to talk to anyone they really and
the way he puts it is
and you also see a lot of obsessive
thinking and he says people are like um
it's like your mind goes into overdrive
of
let me replay that and let me figure out
what can i do in the future to not do
that again
so a lot of the symptoms will look the
same but they're actually
very different kinds of experiences and
the specific patterns that go with those
two different forms of depression seem
to be adaptive given the sort of
context under which they each came about
so the grief depression that is i've
lost somebody that was close to me
presumably this person would have
provided me with support and maybe food
and maybe attention and status perhaps
also
it is in my interests to reach out to
other people because i need to
become more integrated into the tribe
the group around me and i'm going to do
that by reaching out more whereas if i'm
out on a hunt and i mess up and somebody
gets hurt or i cheat on my partner and i
get found out
reaching out to other people in the
tribe when they might think of me badly
is probably not going to be tremendously
effective so something that i can do is
keep myself to myself reduce my energy
expenditure
try and overthink whatever it is that's
just gone on in a desperate attempt to
try and drill that lesson into me and
then move forward dude that's so
interesting
yeah that's so fascinating that i i
didn't think about the the adaptive
effect of depression in that way
yeah yeah he was one thing that i
thought sure
what emotions do you think we would have
felt
in ancestral times that are more rare
now in the modern world
interesting question um i
i know there's there's a guy who passed
away recently unfortunately john
montgomery neuroscientist who became
super interested in evolutionary psych
moved to new york at some point from
california and was doing research in my
lab actually for a while and he
he wrote pretty extensively
about
affective states and emotional states
across nomadic versus westernized kinds
of societies
and his main claim is probably
overstated but he essentially made the
case that what we call mental illness
and things that especially emotional
based mental illness
severe depression
severe anxiety
mood stability issues
what his claim was is that these are
relatively rare in pre-westernized
societies
so
getting it's kind of like uh in a
somewhat roundabout way getting into
your question of what emotional states
would we have experienced in different
proportions i think the extreme
depression anxiety loneliness exactly
exactly and i think part of it is
um that we now have these
contexts these social contexts where
we're
um we're not constantly surrounded by
support we're not constantly surrounded
by family we're not constantly
surrounded by
um secondary family or friends that
we've
been connected with over and over again
extensively like we're now running into
all kinds of situations where we run
into people that are non-relatives who
run into people that are strangers
so we have all these environmental
conditions that are especially socially
that are so different from ancestral
conditions
and
what you find is anxiety and depression
are way more common in urbanized areas
than even in suburban areas or rural
areas or certainly in nomadic kinds of
environments and i feel like from an
evolutionary perspective we can totally
understand this you know so people are
like asking like why well maybe we need
more psychiatrists in large cities maybe
we need better pharmaceuticals you know
this kind of thing maybe we need more
group therapy and i'm not saying that
these are bad things and certainly could
you know could be beneficial but again
the evolutionary perspective really
encourages us to step back and say wait
a minute let's let's take a big picture
look at this and see why is this
happening in the first place
um i wondered whether or
would be an emotion that we might feel a
little bit more ancestrally just that
you know people try and chase that down
now by
going to a movie and seeing really cool
special
effects but
i think our um or radar has been
tuned down a little bit because of what
we can have delivered to us by
technology and also a detachment from
the natural world it's very rare that
you would see a beautiful night sky and
yet the times when you do at least for
me i look up and i think i need to do
this more
i must spend more time staring at the
night sky and then you don't and i think
well why what is it about that the same
as a
a big field a beautiful wide open space
why is it that i like the look of that
well probably because i could see
predators and prey from an absolute mile
off and yet for the most part i
my vision is constrained by walls or
buildings or
the pillars of my car
and
yeah i i felt like all would be
would perhaps be one of them yeah i
think that's a great question you know
there's this concept of a super normal
stimulus and a super normal stimulus is
something that an organism evolved to
respond to and it's like it for some
reason or another usually artificially
by human means there's um
an expanded or amplified version of the
stimulus is is made and a lot of times
you know we can think of of companies as
as making all kinds of products that are
just like like amplified versions of
things that we gravitate towards so you
like food that's high in carbohydrates
and and sugar and salt well here's
mcdonald's you know and it's and it's
cheap on top of that kind of thing so i
feel like um in the modern world we have
things that are just like like
would have been unbelievable under
ancestral conditions would have been
you know a mcdonald's milkshake
20 000 years ago would have been by far
and away the sweetest thing anyone on
earth would have ever experienced and
now you can get one every single day for
like two dollars um you know and so we
get a little bit desensitized to it you
know and then the other part of what
you're talking about chris and i'm a
huge advocate of of the outdoors um
[Music]
and you know i lead hikes on our campus
we have great mountains right here in
new paltz and
try to get outside as much as i as i can
that it there's something to it you know
there really is and i know eo wilson who
passed away recently unfortunately
um huge huge posthumously cancelled as
well passed away and then got posted
that's it's it's too easy he'll come
back though he'll come back
um yeah but he um you know he wrote
about biophilia which is essentially
what you're exactly what you're talking
about which is we have an inherent
natural love of the living world and we
do because our ancestors needed that we
needed to know flora and fauna we needed
to know
where where the water was and when the
water was going to be at a high point
versus a low point you know and
eventually we became very sensitive to
solar events and knowing okay the sun's
rising here that means the days are
going to get longer the days are going
to get shorter
and i feel like the experience of awe
because it's funny at
52 i feel like i find myself chasing
those kinds of experiences and i had
this insight the other day i was talking
with a good friend about the sun you
know and it's it's it's funny because
like where i live i can actually watch
the sun rise right over the hudson river
which on mornings where i catch it it's
just like magical like there's nothing
that beats it and
i can track it i can see now it's
starting to come northward every morning
just a little bit more and a little bit
earlier
and like these things are so like
imagine if you had never seen or
experienced the sun and at some point
just
someone unveiled it and it's like
there's the sun like
nothing in the world could be that
amazing you know it's so beautiful so
powerful when you think about so many
like nomadic groups and ancestral groups
that were like sun worshipers like yeah
because that thing that's that's the
energy for all of us that's providing
everything for all the food that we're
gonna need for our sustenance
um
following that is something that of
course our ancestors would have been
highly attuned to so
you know getting ourselves the real
short message i guess if there is a
message is
step back and think about how can i make
my life more similar to what it would
have been like under ancestral
conditions eating natural foods being
surrounded by people who i
feel real genuine loyalty to toward and
friendship with and kinship with
finding see if that works fine finding
you know finding real love where there's
someone that you actually really
appreciate in a very deep way and
connect with in a deep kind of way
getting into the out of doors you know
eating natural foods it's it's so easy
to just kind of look at your phone and
just you know eat fast food and
and get into these these habits the
modern world you know makes it so easy
to sort of just sit on your butt and do
nothing but
there's there's costs associated with
that that are i think very hard for us
to see so this evolutionary perspective
really i think gets us to sort of step
back and open our eyes and
think about liabilities of modern
technologies and modern living but also
think about well what can i do to sort
of really live a richer life today
it's something that i think about a lot
i think it's something that everybody
thinks about everybody knows
that the things that they do on a daily
basis are probably not all the best for
them right we constantly have this
tension inside of our minds this
uh whether it be productivity guilt or
connection with family guilt or
overwork guilt whatever it is right
there's some sort of shame or resentment
that we have for the way that we've
spent the last 24 hours because we
could have got up earlier and seen the
sauna we should have gone out for a walk
more or we should have called our
parents or we should have done whatever
and
you know previously there wouldn't have
been anything else to do that wasn't
that it would have been the majority of
your life would have been spent outdoors
with your family eating natural foods
because there was no alternative that
was it and it very much is increasingly
i'm thinking about this that we are kind
of trying to reinvent
a happier version of life
that's that's generally what modern the
modern world is right we've tried to
create a happier safer more convenient
version of life for us because otherwise
we'd just still be living on on fields
and planes and it is very much the job i
think of the modern human to try and
think right
what has the world thrown out which
which part of this bath with bath water
was baby and which bit should i have
held on to and um you know that's the
sort of the perennial
challenge that everybody has at the
moment you know how much am i supposed
to how much is it worth me
chasing down
this new job role or this new bit of
status when i don't need any more
status when i i genuinely might take
more pleasure from just getting home an
hour earlier and spending it with my
kids or i might i genuinely might prefer
to just get a job that is five minutes
down the road because i already have
enough money i already have enough
whatever else it is and it means that i
can spend my time training or doing
whatever else it is that i really really
enjoy to do which is again more
naturalistic people that choose to spend
i've been spending a bit of time around
people in new york who have some very
very expensive apartments in one of them
in tribeca i thought for this sort of
money you could probably have
a house and the flights to be able to
get there on three different continents
in some
small little place and which one's going
to give you more satisfaction and it
really is and that's not to say that
there isn't value in having a beautiful
apartment that's convenient and downtown
and your kids can have good education
and all that stuff but
we do get lied to
both by ourselves and by what the people
around us do and by what culture tells
us that we're supposed to do and yeah
very much the
the most effective people that i know
aren't people that are going out and
seeking new information the ones that
are fantastic at filtering the
information that they get
they're the ones that are able to really
discriminate the signal from the noise
and they go okay this is something that
i need this is just this is horse [ __ ] i
don't need this this is probably this
point this doesn't add anything to my
life and um
that convenience is the final sort of
nail in the coffin that when you mix
hypernormal stimuli with always-on
availability it's really different i'm
walking down the street i was going to
the gym earlier on i walked past the
krispy kreme in times square
i thought i'm on my way to the gym why
am i looking at this krispy kreme places
if i want to go to it i'm literally
going to offset this it's because it's
there yeah it's because it's directly in
front of me and because there's
basically no benefit in the here and now
for me doing it the benefit that
there'll be a pain sorry for me to pay
tomorrow or
in a couple of weeks time when i'm not
as lean as i want to be
but yeah man i think um i really hope
that paleo psychology becomes more of a
more of a field that people pay
attention to because i genuinely do
think it's probably got a lot of the
answers to questions that people feel
are super existential and are actually
just mismatches between what their
system is used to and what they're doing
now
yeah yeah i mean i i appreciate i think
you've articulated that really well and
you know certainly a lot of the work
that i've done in the last few years has
really been trying to advance exactly
this
one one angle that you know i've thought
about quite a bit has to do with
government and business organizations
where especially like producers of
technology um so you can imagine you
know the companies that are social media
companies or apple or companies that are
making these technologies wouldn't it be
great
if they
had trainings or personnel or something
some structure
that
connected with explicitly connected with
an evolutionary approach wouldn't it be
great if snapchat and instagram
had people at a very high level with an
understanding of you know this stuff can
be addictive this stuff can be
problematic um
and what can we do understanding human
evol psychology what can we do with this
product to help minimize those
those unforeseen liabilities
what they're doing what these people are
doing they do understand
the evolution or at least in part they
understand it but they're using it to
further magnify the revenue and the time
on the right that they do with these
apps so yeah i think first off you would
need to have a change of philosophy you
know if you give these people a deeper
understanding of how the human brain
works to me that just seems a lot like
you're giving them more leverage to be
able to take people's time away but dude
i think that you're right with that as
well it'd be fantastic if
these technology companies could use the
insights around how our minds work to
make our lives better because they have
it's their choice
yeah what we do with our devices they
could make the apps less addictive they
could make the time that we spend on
them more meaningful to us they could
connect us with stuff that makes us feel
better rather than more outraged and
blah blah
blah and
i wonder whether we're going to look
back in
50 years time at this period in the same
way as us looking back at those ladies
that used to lick the nibs of
the paint brushes that had radium on
them and think what were you doing or
the people that worked in
next to factories that were spewing out
smoke and just see it as
you know this was
a perhaps necessary cost on route to
finding a more refined version of
something that would later be a
completed product but god i'm glad that
i didn't live through that time wow
that's a very powerful idea and to be
honest i think what you're painting is
almost a best-case scenario or that it
gets better that's presuming that it
gets better right right with vr and
metaverse and augmented reality and
neuralink and stuff like that yeah when
you can't escape it anymore if we don't
fix the philosophy problem around this
misalignment between what we want and
what the what the apps do
it just gets deeper right just gets more
embedded yeah i think so i think you're
absolutely right on that
glenn gaye ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
work that you do where should they go oh
well i've got my website glengare.com
and i also have a psychology today blog
called darwin's subterranean world and i
would be more than happy to connect with
people who have questions or want to
engage in discussions so thanks again
yup thanks so much chris appreciate
being on the show what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you